okay hello and welcome to this video and
I playing arm arcs boy f not doing this
right I guess let's say probably Bishop
b5 no nope we should be fine let's try
this maybe I have an idea and
accelerated dragon then I'm not going to
test because it plays f3 what the heck
l-3 looks extremely strange anyway just
like out of the blue f3 okay so if I
take you for mmm can also go a 6 which
shouldn't be all that bad
maybe you're still still equal here it
takes be five I take here I would have
liked to have the Queen still on but
maybe wait can I do no probably not now
it's kind of lame another day that I had
to trade Queen Sam I mean he lost
castling rights and i have i will have
good Bishop sanji 76 huh so wants to
trade stuff should be six I know that
look looks kind of normal
okay so um night before Bishop g7 night
f to check something I had just a big
big dipper trade
I can take Bishop takes root g8 it's
kind of weird but maybe we should before
I can castle long or play up the aid
yeah so we get this when my rook is
converted in a funk is spot-on hoops on
g7 but the e porn at least some cause
for concern for him so I'm trying to go
there directly with the king use the
king
brooke a forum might be at something but
he has before probably doesn't do all
that much so i think i would probably
want to trade one will come just one
taking now is this a bit too lame so I
try to get in those root a for ideas got
there I go you've got the more active
King so this ending is more comfortable
for black quite clearly but can you
really get something real going for and
play for win
c5 and then before looks like I'm
weakening myself that distance doesn't
really strike me as being very
trustworthy see doing something here no
when xe4 wife okay
if I do this and then repay for
threatening two pawns check check so
maybe this is something to force him to
do a passive defense move now that could
be an idea
not clear that I really benefit much but
still should be three okay but should be
three I can this one okay and some
rookie for it said something or is that
too lame yeah I don't like my pawn
structure in that deadline what if i go
f6 here if we place the rook like the
eighth yeah now d 4 is more interesting
before I'm sorry it's more interesting
ok I have to speed up here also
anyway i'm getting i'm giving him an
island a bass of it I need to get get to
the points here and my points were
rather weak then strong so let's see
here i also have Bishop g4 doesn't do
much it doesn't move though look 250
came castle first of all pushing back
and now yeah maybe maybe this I mean I
know it it looks hot yeah that I wanted
this no Bishop g4 is more more of a
problem for him some [ __ ] chief orgy
fire let's push I'm getting a pond a
passive there and he still cannot move
his rock end dupuy morning looks nice I
mean one thing is I don't really have
many bonds left this is often a problem
but the king of kind of happy here looks
very active yeah you can you can create
suks wanna be sure to form type am very
hard
I don't know about this at age 32 age
three and this should win actually on
Bishop f1 chap Goodwin's chap white
resides yeah I was a little slow grind
which probably um he could defend but it
wasn't it wasn't fun mmm then opening
was extremely weird f3 and I did not
really exploit that to the fullest it
really looks strange yeah maybe just
Bishop g7 what the engine wants to do
okay at this engine he was evil is cool
white is clearly better show me so this
this and this sorry ok this is this
thing so don't believe it where it kind
of goes down down to normal proportions
yeah Bishop g7 is probably better I mean
that what we had also isn't that great i
mean that this is this kind of thing so
when I have 692 councils castles maybe
was better I don't know yeah I think
this was this was an interesting try at
least now here if he does something else
I mean where is he going I'm threatening
this we should before I can can cancel
long so take stakes and now I'm directly
going up to the to e5 and here this is
this is a slow grind I need to trade one
looks so that my king is safer
and now come from here yeah it's it's a
little something it is a little
something if six mostly waiting and now
i got those trades and I know the engine
doesn't really think of it it that much
but something else there i roped you for
our Tea for that's good young rookie
form that would have saved him probably
if I go back as the engine suggests I'm
winning a porn back I mean I'm getting
one porn back somehow I there all week
but I cannot win the game anymore okay
that was his defense and now it gets
extremely annoying top yeah approve g3
so that i'm having a little bit easier
here and here it starts to be a cig la
step yeah that's a grid the engine
agrees cap in hot invasion time invasion
time yeah okay i think i'm happy with
the technical part at the end so yet
science is to Jehol would but this is
happening quite often if you just have a
little something perfect defense will
hold with you have to try as much as
possible ok guys thanks for watching